alors que le compte à rebours vers mars se poursuit,
la persévérance de l'humanité lance
la prochaine génération d'explorateurs robotiques
sur la planète rouge
et atlas tu est passé au
contrôle en boucle fermée
[Musique
] à 30 secondes de vol, le
rd-180 ralentit comme prévu
moteur  la réponse semble bonne
et mach 1 atlas 5 est maintenant supersonique
et passe 45 secondes en vol le
véhicule passe maintenant par max q
pression dynamique maximale
et passe une minute en vol le
rd-180 ralentit comme prévu
la réponse du moteur semble bonne à ce moment
en vol, les pressions de la chambre srv
restent nominales,
la vitesse de la pompe rd-180 et les
pressions de l'injecteur de carburant répondent bien aux demandes
du moteur
en attente d'épuisement srb sous peu
et nous avons un épuisement sur les quatre
signatures de pression d'épuisement srbs semblent bonnes
en attente de largage srb  bientôt
vous